la storia di ii generazione la
generazione di mauro che è nato nel 1950
degli anni e rampanti del boom economico
finisce il liceo nel 68 in piedi 68 poi
si iscrive all'università palla prodotta
di economia la completa con calma senza
dannarsi l'anima sono gli anni del
lavoro di gruppo ed a vuoto politico
entra sul mercato del lavoro al 77
quando reddito medio degli italiani
vedete quella curva blu del grafico sta
crescendo 6 per cento crociera ci sono
state delle crisi però avuto il primo al
secondo shock petrolifero ma sono state
delle brevi parenti la disoccupazione
dieci settimane a quello medio degli
italiani da parte di una laura cela il
debito pubblico e la linea rossa
assoluto paga circa il 25 per cento del
suo stipendio in tasse quindi 75 per
cento e interesserà in tasca solo la
pressione fiscale quindi molto bassa
il debito aumenterà soltanto di via
qualche anno ed aumenterà soprattutto
per fare delle cose favorevoli alla
generazione di paolo che era dei posti
di lavoro nel pubblico
quattro su dieci dei suoi coetanei
troveranno lavoro in qualche modo legato
al settore pubblico e poi servirà al
debito pubblico per dare delle pensioni
molto generose alle persone della
generazione di paolo
in effetti paolo andato in pensione nel
2004 gli è stato aumentato il salario
l'ultimo anno del suo lavoro per
permettergli di poter ricevere per il
resto della sua vita
una pensione che pari al 90 per cento
della sua ultima retribuzione e poi
invece c'è la generazione di federica
federica è nata nel 1983 ha fatto
esattamente la stessa carriera
scolastica e universitaria paolo anche
lei si è iscritta ad economia è stata
più dura perché l'università e la scuola
erano sicuramente più selettive
eppure lei ce l'ha fatta è riuscita a
prendere cento alla laurea
lo stesso voto che ha preso paolo però
avuto la sfortuna di entrare nel mercato
del lavoro nel 2008 un anno in cui il
reddito medio degli italiani anzi crash
crescerà 6 per cento come nel caso di
paolo è diminuito del 6 per cento e nei
sei anni successivi non è ancora
riuscita a trovare un lavoro stabile ha
dovuto imparare dei nomignoli strani
degli acronimi co.co.pro co.co.co
a spa la spagna è stato detto che è un
lavoro che non solo unisce il rischio di
perderlo al fatto di prendersi un pò
carico dei rischi dell'impresa
e su ogni reddito che guadagna deve
pagare delle tasse che sono il doppio di
quelli che pagava la generazione
precedente con la prospettiva poi di
andare in pensione con una pensione
molto bassa bene la situazione e le
difficoltà che oggi federica sta
incontrando nel mercato del lavoro si
devono a questa situazione al fatto che
c'è un divario molto importante che si è
consumata che si produce oggi contro i
giovani il debito pubblico
ve lo faceva vedere il grafico
precedente è tornato a essere a circa il
130 per cento però questo debito
pubblico non viene utilizzato per dare
dei servizi alla generazione di paola la
generazione di paola deve pagare delle
tasse svedesi avendo dei servizi
pubblici che sono assolutamente non in
grado di soddisfarla non vengono
garantite delle scuole migliori una
formazione migliore
quei soldi servono soprattutto per
pagare gli oneri sul debito pubblico il
paradosso che paola non trova lavoro e
deve spiegare a tutti che cos'è lo
spread un termine che nessuno conosceva
prima ma c'è un altro spread che forse
meno conosciuto che mai giudizio è
ancora più grave dello spread sui titoli
di stato e dello spread nei tassi di
disoccupazione ve lo fa vedere questo
grafico non c'è paese in cui ci sia un
divario così forte tra la disoccupazione
dei giovani la disoccupazione degli
altri gruppi di età dell'italia tre
volte tanto la media non c'è un altro
paese in cui i giovani si sa né una
situazione al 33 relativamente così
sfavorevole come il nostro l'italia non
è un paese per giovani è un paese che ha
voltato le spalle ai giovani ma non
siamo qui per piangere addosso non siete
qui per piangervi addosso non siete qui
per preparare le valigie ne siete qui
per chiedere aiuto ai vostri genitori i
vostri genitori in realtà dell'aiuto a
velo danno i genitori italiani sono
molto attenti ai loro figli le mamme
italiane addirittura passano più tempo
al telefono dei figli delle mamme di
tutti gli altri paesi dell'europea forse
fin troppo
il problema è che non pensano a voi le
generazioni di paolo non
insomma i problemi dei giovani nelle
scelte pubbliche non fanno la pressione
su chi deve prendere le decisioni
importanti nel modo giusto
avviene così che nell'ultimo anno per
esempio si è discusso al governo
politica confronti talk show quasi solo
della tassazione della casa questa
scioglilingua che siamo passati a
parlare del limo della tarsu tasi e così
via si è parlato solo di quello ma cosa
riguarda questi giovani quanti giovani
oggi possiedono una casa solo il 5 per
cento del patrimonio immobiliare in
italia è appannaggio di famiglie il cui
capofamiglia ha meno di 30 anni mentre
invece una cosa che riguarda tantissimi
giovani sono le tasse che devono pagare
sul lavoro che ripeto portano via più
del 50 per cento di quello che uno
guadagna questo è il problema numero né
perché nessuno si occupa invece di
cercare di ridurre le tasse sul lavoro
quindi questa è una prima cosa che
bisogna chiedere alle generazioni di
paolo votate e fate cambiare questa
classe politica impone da questa classe
politica di affrontare questo problema e
di abbassare le tasse sul lavoro e
bisogna anche cambiare il modo con cui
vengono fatte perché le nostre tasse
nostro sistema fiscale fa di tutto per
tenere le donne fuori dal mercato del
lavoro le aiuta a stare fuori le spinge
a stare a casa con le detrazioni per i
coni già carico anziché usare quelle
risorse per far aumentare anche il
potere contrattuale delle donne
all'interno della famiglia e permettere
loro di lavorare guadagnando di più c'è
un'altra cosa importante che bisogna
chiedere la generazione di paolo
cambiare le regole di ingresso nel
mercato del lavoro ce ne parla da tanto
tempo ma nessuno lo sta facendo bene
non è possibile che chi entra oggi nel
mercato del lavoro debba solo vedersi
proposti dei contratti che hanno una
scadenza come i prodotti che troviamo
sugli scaffali dei supermercati
bisogna poter entrare avendo fin da
subito un contratto a tempo
indeterminato
certo un contratto che magari non da
subito da tutte le tutele che vengono
garantite a chi ha più di vent'anni
all'interno dell'azienda perché anche
giusto che datore di lavoro impari
capisca quali sono le capacità del
proprio dipendente che inizialmente non
finiranno mai un contratto a tempo
indeterminato se licenziarvi dopo un
giorno triste lì costa come licenziare
insomma che è stata 20 anni all'interno
di quell azienda quindi ci vuole un
contratto che crea delle tutele
progressive più rimanete in quel lavoro
più vida delle tutele nel caso del
licenziamento senza giusta causa ma
anche nel caso di in cui ci sia giusta
causa
questa è l'idea del contratto a tutele
progressive qualcosa che unifica i
canali del mercato del lavoro e dando vi
un contratto a tutele progressive voi
supererete anche questa simmetria che
c'è nelle retribuzioni perché vedete
questo è il salario di chi entrava nel
mercato del lavoro a vedete qui e quando
è entrato nel mercato del lavoro paolo
guadagnava di più della media degli
italiani
la linea rossa oggi si entra nel mercato
del lavoro e si guadagna di meno della
media degli italiani anche come federica
quando si ha una laurea che vuol dire
avere un titolo di studio superiore a
quello della media degli italiani e poi
da lì progredisce si rimane lì perché si
è segregati se in un altro mercato del
lavoro parallelo completamente diverso
in cui non ci sono dei vasi comunicanti
ma c'è un altro problema legato al fatto
che si è segregati e cioè il fatto che
avendo un contratto che ha una durata
limitata non si investe nella formazione
della formazione davvero fondamentale
perché questa è la cosa che vi dà
davvero sicurezza perché vi rende meno
sostituibili con altri la formazione sul
posto di lavoro e di tale non si fa non
la si fa più sui giovani che sono quelli
su cui il datore di lavoro dovrebbe
investire perché il costo che uno ha nel
formare un giovane viene ammortizzato su
tutta la carriera lavorativa dei giovani
bene guardate questo grafico cosa vi
dice vi dice che in italia meno del 10
per cento dei giovani riceve formazioni
sul posto di lavoro è un fatto
gravissimo e anche su questo purtroppo
siamo il fanalino di coda sia essi
peggio degli altri paesi è un fatto
molto grave bisogna certamente allungare
la durata dei contratti partire subito
con un contratto a tempo determinato in
modo tale che ci siano gli incentivi
giusti per il datore di lavoro e anche
per i lavoratori a investire in
formazione ma bisogna fare anche altro
bisogna migliorare il passaggio dalla
scuola al mercato del lavoro
guardate qui ci sono alcuni paesi che
fanno nettamente meglio di noi la
germania l'austria l'olanda
loro hanno un sistema per cui
finita la scuola secondaria si ha
accesso a delle scuole di
specializzazione che fanno sì che nel
giro di qualche anno uno riesca ad
acquisire quelle competenze intermedie
che sono altamente domandate dal mondo
delle imprese sono corsi relativamente
brevi durano 2 3 anni e ripeto in questi
anni uno guadagna anche qualcosa perché
passa metà del tempo nelle aule
universitarie nell'istruzione formale e
l'altra metà del tempo la passa invece
in azienda a lavorare a imparare in
azienda e la cosa importante che
l'università controlla che l'azienda
forme non come i 2000 e più contratti di
formazione di cui si parla in italia
dove il contenuto formativo è zero è
solo un modo per il datore di lavoro di
pagare di meno il lavoratore qui
universi controllerebbe e l'azienda
avrebbe anche lei tutti gli incentivi
per controllare che il l'università
accesso mestiere nel formare il
lavoratore questa è una cosa che noi
dobbiamo creare ma dobbiamo anche
pensare che se noi dovessimo fare tutte
le cose che vi ho detto prima abbassare
le tasse un contratto diverso
questo miglioramento del passaggio tra
scuola e lavoro ci sarà sempre qualcuno
che sarà sfortunato che cadrà tra le
crepe della società perché ha avuto la
sfortuna di venire licenziato di andare
nell'impresa sbagliata di prendere il
posto di lavoro nel dell'indirizzo nel
posto che è in crisi
bene oggi non esistono dei paracaduti
per i giovani che perdono il lavoro i
paracaduti esistono solo per chi ha
l'età pensionabile non c'è un sistema
come un reddito minimo garantito che
serve ad assicurare a portare al di
fuori delle condizioni di indigenza i
poveri e l'abbiamo visto nel caso
dell'ultima recessione 6 fino a 20 anni
fa la probabilità di essere povero tra i
giovani era più bassa che per le altre
fasce d'età
nell'ultima recessione la vedete questa
sbarra rossa vedete come aumentata come
è diventata superiore a quella di tutti
gli altri gruppi d'età
qui ci vuole un sistema di protezione di
base un reddito minimo garantito che va
da tutelare a impedire ai giovani di
cadere in condizioni di indigenza costa
certamente ha dei costi fiscali ma sono
molto molto molto più bassi dei costi
che noi paghiamo tutti gli anni per
garantire delle pensioni elevate a chi
ha pagato dei contributi molto bassi che
magari pensieri superiori a 4 mila euro
al mese e che ha versato molto meno
contributi che non sono minimamente
giustificate alla luce dei contributi
versati
allora perché non chiedere un contributo
e riceve dell'età kima
come i giudici della corte
costituzionale magari avendo fatto due
anni con quel mandato vanno in pensione
anno 20mila euro al mese di pensione
perché non chiedere un contributo ai
vice camandante dell'arma dei
carabinieri lo abbiamo documentato sulla
voce recentemente che nel mezzo di
questa crisi pesantissima sono riusciti
a farsi raddoppiare le pensioni perché
si sono inventati dei pagamenti che
avevano fatti negli anni precedenti ai
quei soldi non hanno mai pagate al
sistema pensionistico
bene io credo che c'è un principio
giusto il nostro sistema fiscale a chi
ha di più di dare di più io credo che
sia giusta anche a chiedere a chi ha
avuto di più è molto di più di quello
che ha versato durante la sua carriera
lavorativa oggi di dare di più per dare
una protezione ai giovani vedete paolo e
federica non possono fare l'uno a meno
dell'altra federica nei pochi lavori che
ha sta pagando la pensione di paolo e
paolo deve aiutare federica risolvere i
problemi che vi menzionavo prima facendo
quelle scelte di politica perché di
fatto è quella generazione che oggi
condiziona le scelte politiche ma c'è
un'altra ragione fondamentale per cui
paolo non può fare a meno di federica
una nazione un paese che dimostra di non
saper investire nei giovani non ha
proprio un futuro